I first found you on Twitter okay
there's a female Ben Shapiro and I saw
the resemblance and I thought okay you
guys are related somehow we are not
related although you gave me the great
idea that we should do a DNA test just
to see if there's any there might be
something yeah I mean because I didn't
see it I think it's the eyebrows but I
really don't know we should actually do
a side by side a lot of people said oh
you know you're right wing you probably
like grew up watching Ben like that's
why you talk I'm like literally no we
just speak very very quickly and talk
with our hands a lot apparently so yeah
I am a daily wire now I host the comment
section